thousand dollars
maybe step two is the debt snowball pay
off all your debt except your
home and baby step you to using the debt
snowball see your largest wealth
building tool is your income and when
you give your income to other people
called banks they have nicer furniture
and bigger buildings than you have do
you think Santa Claus built those
buildings you did you gave all of your
sweat to someone else for a couch for a
car for a swimming pool you couldn't
afford we know you couldn't afford it
because you didn't pay for it and it's
easy payments who ever had any easy
payments this is not y'all you will
never win with money as long as you
struggle with that as long as you
justify and rationalize and you're
normalized the use of debt when you
don't have any payments breathe that in
no Vance I can't even fathom the sense
of freedom the sense of release
that's so much freakin money and when
you start putting it into investments
instead of into payments it turns into
all a lot of money for you and for you
to be generous and for you to change
your family tree and for you to live
life large and enjoy things but living
without that our culture has so
normalized it and rationalized it that
you people will think you're weird if
you don't borrow money because you will
be normal is broke normal is living
paycheck to paycheck work your whole
life like a rat in the wheel and come to
retirement gosh sure hope the government
which is well known for its ability to
handle money will take care of me
that's dumber than a rock and we got a
whole culture doing this it's past time
for a renaissance in the art of personal
finance it's time it's time to live
without debt in a culture that is
normalized this requires a whole new way
of looking at things me tell you how you
get a new way of looking at things you
do what you're doing tonight you get new
information you didn't have you ever
read a book or read the Bible or you
went to a course on marriage or you did
whatever and you got a new way of
looking at things and it changed
everything in learning we call that a
paradigm shift it was a big thing back
in the 80s everybody listened to the
paradigms
but all that is is your paradigm is your
way of looking at things and the way
you're looking at them now got you where
you are so we need to change that let's
have a different way of looking at
things and that's warning that's all it
is
let me show you a visual paradigm as an
example you will learn in the next few
moments watch
all the female voices that we're about
to go protest because you put
punctuation on something that I didn't
isn't that great well for those of you
that don't know I hope you're this for
the drive home the correct answer is the
last one okay but isn't it interesting
that you depending on how you punctuate
that the meaning of the sentence
completely changes 180s completely
changes and yet some of you with no
punctuation punctuated it one way or the
other now you've seen both you've
learned you will never again see that
sentence and be tricked by that it's now
stored in your hard drive and so you
have learned there's a new way of
looking at things so aha here we go
through here ah that was kind of a
female relaxing I don't have to kill him
it's like make sense Khan was coming out
there y'all ready to shoot me and I
didn't do it you did it it's not fun so
you get a different way of looking at
things by punctuating it properly and
you get the right answer at the last
here's another one look at this one the
rich rules over the poor and the
borrower is slave to the lender will get
out of school with student loan most of
us got a free t-shirt and got some
credit cards while we were on campus
changed our financial life they got home
and got our first big board job big girl
job and Shannon was driving a 1902 Pinto
you remember those cars that used to
explode I got all embarrassed and what
bought her a car that I wanted you near
that did you
how many you guys have ever bought your
wife a car you wanted yeah I'm sure she
liked it it's a hot rod but I'm sure
she'll like it and then of course you've
been married for 20 minutes and
everybody's like get a house get a house
get a house get a house you got to get a
house if you don't get a house you're
gonna be a renter and renters go to hell
you can't be already can be a rancher uh
my house my house and so broke people go
buy houses and if enough broke people
buy houses at one time and the
government helps and causes mortgage
companies to completely lose their mind
you could like turn the whole economy
upside down
maybe I old enough to remember 2008 and
so we have couples that come in our
office that look like this every day
they're like Dave can you get me out
yeah it's gonna hurt we're gonna have to
amputate the Tahoe
you mean I gotta sell my car uh-huh you
owe 52,000 on it and you make 26 your
harsh new I am loving loving telling you
this Shannon I figured out that this is
the truth we had a paradigm shift we
said we don't borrow money anymore you
don't borrow money nope don't borrow
money you know what you can do when you
don't have any payments anything you
want think about it just take a couple
of car payments to start multiplying my
car payment America today the average
car payment is five hundred six dollars
over 84 months according the national
auto dealers association invest five
hundred and six dollars from age 30 to
age 65 in a decent growth stock mutual
fund you'll have 5.6 million dollars in
your 401k hope you like the car this is
the power of debt it steals your
economic muscle and deposits it in
someone else's account after you worked
your butt off it's got to stop and we
quit giving our money away to other
people the only money we give away now
is charity and ministries and generosity
and dadgum taxes and that's all we do
and so I only got one thing to be mad
about every year taxes I'm not mad to
bank because the bank doesn't come to my
office except to try to figure out how
to get our millions of dollars of
deposits and so I went from hillbilly to
dealing with Beverly Hillbillies and mr.
Drysdale all right Davey wants your
business no I don't really want only
white bankers if you're a banker I love
you but I don't really like you I just
do you and Dave everybody here everybody
you have to have a have to have a credit
card if you don't have a credit card
really that's my wallet got green
presidents faces
four pieces of plastic a debit card on
my business a debit card on my personal
account my driver's license and my
handgun carry for a minute oh there's
still rednecks in South Carolina huh
I was in California though today and I
said that I about got arrested good to
be back in America but oh my god
oh we're just playing with you people in
California watching on the stream we
love you just stay over there okay but
[Applause]
well David everybody's got a car payment
oh boy everybody calls me on the show
with a car payment question they
borrowed by a car what about my car Pam
oh boy call me from Texas needs like
baby you're gonna kill me I'm not gonna
kill you you're in Texas I'm in
Tennessee how am I gonna kill you
what'd you do my truck paper how much is
your truck payment seven hundred $69 are
you kidding me this is a fine truck he
goes no Dave it's a fine truck what's
killing me I said I think how much is
your house payment you said what we live
in a double-wide it's 550
[Applause]
dude if your truck payments bigger than
your house payment you might be a
redneck
okay amazing what happens when you get
out of debt Dave I need a FICO score why
you're gonna go in debt so that you can
get a score it allows you to go into
debt so that you can get a score it
allows you to go into debt so that you
can get a score it allows you're going
to debt your FICO score is nothing to do
with your income or your net worth it is
not a measure of financially winning
it's a measure of how much you have
played kissy-face with a bank
mathematically the algorithm states that
quit worshipping at the altar of the
great FICO oh great FICO we bring you
offerings of interest and you give us
stuff we can't afford thank you oh great
FICO please run my score up great FICO
the people come up to me I have an 800
score and I'm going I'm so sorry it cost
you 150 grand easy and interest there's
no possible way to get one my FICO score
zero I don't have one it's
indeterminable
which is awesome I just pay for stuff if
I don't have the money I don't buy it
Wow that's deep it works - the Bible
says a foolish man devours all he has
you spend everything you make your fool
and that's a biblical fool I didn't say
you're a fool God said you're a fool
don't blame me don't spend everything
you make and don't put yourself in debt
you're a slave and you know the
interesting thing is getting out of debt
is not a math thing as much as I thought
it was I'm a math nerd I've always been
good at numbers I can just do numbers
I'm just the numbers I do on the air
when you hear the radio sometimes I put
that in the calculator but 90% of the
numbers I'm just stirring around my head
I've been doing a long time I can do big
number math real fast I can get pretty
close on most of this stuff and I'm just
kind of okay you did this and this and
I'm looking at the ratio of this I can
just see stuff in the numbers it's easy
for me so I thought if we fix the math
it would get people out of that so I
just need to show them how to fix the
math it's not laughter because I would
have a single mom making $34,000 here
that would pay off $100,000 in four
years and I'd have somebody making
$100,000 that calls me up they got
thirty four thousand dollars in debt and
then I'm stuck we mean I just talked to
a single mom makes a third of what you
make and she paid off more than you make
and you're stuck
Queeny you're stuck hope you don't have
hope when you don't believe you can you
can't do anything Henry Ford you should
say if you think you can or you think
you can't you're right the Bible says
Hope deferred makes the heart sick but
when desire comes it is the tree of life
and so I start realizing it was about
what was happening inside of people's
heart in their hope factor the ratio of
their hope to the problem how much they
were fired up how much they were they've
had an I've had it moment when you say
I've had it my momma used to say the
worm has turned
we even know what that meant
we just knew the beatings were about to
begin right you know looked it up
finally I found out Shakespeare said
that mom knew Shakespeare but there you
go
things you don't know about your mom
when you're a kid I'm mad but you got to
have that moment that's it I've had it
so I'm reading through proverbs because
there's 31 of them if you read one a day
you can go through them in a month and
in 12 times a year
and if you read proverbs over and over
again you'll have a master's degree in
finance even if you're not a person of
faith it is the book of wisdom okay and
there's wisdom in there whether you
agree with the source or either read so
I'm reading through there and I'm you
know I always get something different
about once a year I hit something oh wow
and so I'm reading and I saw the formula
because I'll think of math terms I said
if you've signed surety my son which is
Old English Bible talk forgotten
yourself in the debt
okay I'm reading King John New King
James Version that's what I was reading
right there
if you sound surety my son do this now
that's a formula here it problem answer
to the problem other side of those words
do this y'all have that if you got this
problem God says do this and I'm like
there it is
this is how you get out of debt this is
how those people are getting out of debt
they're doing their debt free screams
and I can't figure out how the ones that
don't make as much as the ones that make
are doing it this is what they're doing
what are you doing it says give no sleep
to your eyes no slumber to your eyelids
okay I got that go to work I got that
and deliver yourself like a gazelle from
the hand of the hunter a bird from the
hand of the Fowler now I know some of
you are holy people and you're like
reverent with God but me and God just
talked and he's not scared of me and so
I just I'm like I gotta do this God you
said get out of that do this and then
you give me an animal metaphor I don't
get it power you don't run gazelle what
are you talking about I don't yeah
so scanning the Discovery Channel that
night and I hit the Discovery Channel
and there were the gazelles they were
out there good selling around i sir
I was just reading about you boys so I
stopped my scanner I set the changer
down what's happening now you know that
the gazelles are not there by themselves
if the Discovery Channel is there you
know someone else is on the scene mr.
cheetah is looking for lunch in all the
right places now I don't know if you
know this but gazelles have a little
cheetah detector behind their ear and
when they see him or hear him they go
cheat because here's some actual facts
the cheetah is the fastest mammal on dry
land it can go from zero to sixty seven
miles an hour and four leaps they have
been clocked as high as running 82 miles
an hour we had to slow this down so I'd
have time to talk this is the fastest
baddest predator on the planet and he's
after lunch he's trying to go through
the drive-through he picked out a
college student come here kid
come here kit kid you need to get you a
cell phone you've got to build up your
FICO score come here kid I'll give you a
t-shirt for that credit card come here
kid come here kid and the God says this
is how you get out of debt you deliver
yourself like a gazelle from the hem of
the hunter you want to get out of debt
you got a rug you got to put it in gear
you got a bust
[Applause]
nananananana
you know how long we had to look for a
quick clip where they get away here's
what's interesting the Discovery Channel
went on to tell us that night then in
times they've clocked these chases and
that hundreds and hundreds even
thousands of times and the animal
experts tell us this is about true that
the Gazelle is only captured by the
cheetah one in nineteen times now here's
what's interesting about that metaphor
the cheetah is faster he's bigger he's
really scary he's a he's a cat he's a
dude and yet he only wins one of
nineteen times I'm thinking how does the
inferior gazelle get away one out of I
mean nine eight seven to 18 out of 19
times I'm thinking about I went Oh
motivation
ghazal loses the chase he dies Cheeta
loses the chase he chases another
gazelle later no big deal
get me a slower one next time right now
this is what the word that says deliver
yourself hey have you got me out of debt
I ain't never get anybody out of debt I
showed you how I made you believe it
could deliver yourself the government's
not coming they're stupid deliver
yourself you're not gonna win the lotto
deliver yourself don't wait on a race
you'll spend it anyway deliver yourself
like you're running for your life we
call that gazelle intensity around our
place and that single mom making 30 for
the paid off 100 she had gazelle
intensity
she was invested in not being lunch
anymore that guy making a hundred that
can't seem to find a way to pay you off
34 he's scheduled a wandering about the
tundra hungry he's next deliver yourself
like your life depends on it that's what
this says so how do you get out of debt
well I'm number one you quit borrowing
more money no that's deep you can't get
out of a hole while you're digging out
the bottom so don't tell me about I'm
going on vacation and then I'm gonna
work on this up you need to go home
tonight get your credit cards out light
a candle and have a plastic surgery
celebration I have met with thousands of
millionaires I've never met a
millionaire that says you know David I
made all my money with my airline miles
that's the biggest bunch of hogwash and
everybody's so stupid they like trying
to be sophisticated and justify I make
money on my credit cards
please just open up bankamerica please
just open up chase
please just look at Wells Fargo open up
the credit card section in their
financial statements and tell me that
again that's the dumbest but statement I
ever heard in my life you're whipping
these multi-billion dollar corporations
who have more in depth behavior Studies
on you do they know more about how
you're gonna behave than you know
they're tracking you through all your
Google and all your all your moves
Google Analytics are telling them
exactly who you are
what kind of freaking bottled water you
buy and you're gonna outsmart them keep
playing with snakes bozo you're gonna
get bit that's how this works I got rid
of mine Capital One what's in your
wallet money
Wells Fargo twenty four thousand
employees fired for fraud they have
twenty four thousand employees
no they had a hundred something thousand
employees and a fourth of them were
crooks this is hard to Bank of America
why anybody do business those people
unbelievable Citibank in American
distress she
target that's what's on your butt listen
guys come on really all these places
take cash all these places let you play
with your debit card I travel all over
the world I rent cars let's stay in fine
hotels I woke up a handle my debit card
mister mg but we will take your money
every time it's different yeah it's
different quit borrowing money if you
want to get out of debt second one is
you need to save money maybe step ones a
thousand dollars everybody say thousand
dollars hey yourself first start with a
thousand dollars that's baby step one
and then we're gonna work our way into
saving afterwards next one is sell some
stuff sell so much stuff the kids think
their next name the dog eBay put the cat
on Craigslist children are trembling dad
please don't little Johnny we like him
you got abyss quit your love affair with
stuff godliness with contentment is a
great game starts relaxing the striving
for the acquisition of trash for the
next year's garage sale is unbelievable
I mean no other culture in the world
when we move has a box that says seldom
used kitchen items
only in a culture like ours where we're
just obliterated with stuff I'm not
against you getting some stuff but we're
not I control y'all take a part-time job
take some overtime my grandmother used
to say there's a great place to go when
you're broke to work
you can make 1,500 bucks a month
delivering pizzas four nights a week
well I don't know I have a master's
degree and you're broke I don't care if
you deliver pizzas or not but get your
button gear let's do something sit home
and watch HBO reruns and think Bruce
Willis is gonna change your life
it's not gonna happen not gonna happen
you got to do it you deliver your self
and the last one is prayer really works
now I don't know where you are on your
faith journey or if you even realize
your own one but I do know this whether
you know it or not your heavenly
father's absolutely crazy about you
he thinks you're amazing and he's really
rich the Bible says he owns the cattle
on a Thousand Hills oh by the way he
owns the hills your dad loves you and
he's really rich and you're in that
phone home me T check-in well I can't I
don't know if I could pray or not huh
he's probably mad at me you don't know
about all the stuff I did he's not mad
at you sometimes you make him laugh I
mean you know think about how many y'all
got enough kids that you got a stupid
one don't raise your hand if you're
sitting with Oh
we think about your Heavenly Father he's
got some stupid children
he looked down at me when I was doing
all that stuff he's an egg Gabriel come
here watch that one oh that's gonna
leave a mark it did it changed my life
he's crazy about you
and if you just start talking to him
that's called prayer and you start
having a real conversation with him his
love letter says he's gonna throw a
party put a gold ring on your finger and
new suit of clothes on you and serve
filet mignon at the party it's in there
look it up it's called the prodigal son
and it's real most of us have been that
at one time or another in our lives so
check in it works now we're gonna be on
baby step one we're not investing
anywhere we're squeezing every dollar
out of our budget
we're building up all the money we can
get from working extra and everything
else and we're gonna start attacking our
debts using the debt snowball the debt
snowballs where you list your debts
smallest to largest
you pay minimum payments on everything
but the little one and you attack with a
little one with that gazelle intensity
you attack it as fast as you can as hard
as you can regardless of the interest
rate well David wouldn't it be
mathematically correct to pay out the
highest interest rate first yes it would
but if we were doing math we wouldn't
have credit card debt this is not a math
problem this is a behavior problem and a
paradigm problem and you solve those
problems with paradigm and behavior
solutions not math solutions
consequently millions and millions and
millions of people have gotten out of
debt using this and all the other crap
you read about on the internet added
together Danny Matt up to a tenth of
what we've been able to do using this
simple idea because when you pay off a
little debt you go wow then you pay off
another one you're like yeah when you
pay off another one right the more you
pay off the more excited you get the
more excited you get you start to
believe your hope goes up as your hope
goes up you sacrifice even deeper you
cut deeper the more you cut the more you
work the faster you get out and as soon
as you pay off one of those debts take
all the payments from that type pay the
next one down and all the money is freed
up from that you pay it on the next one
down and everything else we can find
then you paid on the next one then you
paid on the next one the snowball rolls
down the hole
that's how it's done you guys your
largest wealth building tool is your
for years decades we at Ramsay have been
teaching people how to handle money and
how to win with it we've had millions of
people use this and change their family
tree over 6 million of them have been
through Financial Peace University in
the last 36 months we have backed up and
looked at the way we're doing this and
are really thinking it through it's a
pretty incredible time in our
organization we've got all these data
points we've got all this experience
we've got all this proof text in the
market and we're starting to look at it
and we've realized that simply teaching
people and walking them through the 9
week class Financial Peace University
wasn't enough or we have had incredible
results with that but it didn't enough
and so we've been really working hard to
design a way for you to go further and
faster than ever before doing the stuff
we teach and we've got this so polished
and so dialed in we're living out this
plan goes into high gear and so we've
rebuilt the financial piece membership
membership has everything that you're
going to need to my win with money in
one place of course the financial piece
membership includes the not only Class
Financial Peace University everybody
knows about that a lot how many of
you've already been through the class
awesome ok and it's incredible it has
amazing results but when you go out the
back of that class unless you turn
around and be a coordinator you can run
out of steam because you kind of kind of
drift off out of the stuff right and so
we're we've been observing this and so
the financial piece membership includes
access to the financial piece we also
put in there every dollar Plus which is
the connectivity to your bank in the
every dollar app and that means you put
your bank in there and every time use
your debit card it shows up right there
in your budget and so you can keep up
with your budget faster easier quicker
and you're more likely to do it and the
more you do your budget the more you
stay on track executing the details of
this project which is called wealth
building each of those we used to charge
over a hundred dollars for we're
including both of them in this now and
the whole thing is a deal now it also
includes bonus courses like the legacy
journey which
the follow-up class to Financial Peace
University that a whole bunch of you
have not been through yet it's in there
smart money smart kids which is a class
taught by my daughter number one
best-selling author two times Rachael
Cruz the first one was called smart
money smart kids where she and I talked
about how we taught our kids how to
handle money for your parents how to
break the chains off of your generation
teach your kids how to handle money then
we put in there the community and you
get on here with the community our
online community is a village and they
are hardcore
I mean it's like their demeanor and ion
they will you get in there there do this
stuff man their because they we want
everybody to win everybody it's all
positive peer pressure lifting you to
where you want to go it changes
everything we put our toolkit in there
there's all kinds of goodies in there
we'll talk about some more of those
through the night but I mean there's all
kinds of stuff we're adding all the time
and you've got access to the Rams of
coaches as well all of this is in one
pile and you can't beat this this is
this is gonna speed up the effect of
Financial Peace University and extend it
that's the key part the last parts
important extend it past nine weeks
that's very very important so we can
stay with you and keep working with you
and keep feeding things and for tonight
we're gonna add in one book free and so
you get financial peace membership and
one book free this bundle is normally
$129 the plus the book which is another
20 bucks so that's about $140 bundle
usually $149 bundle and tonight of
course it's $99 always a seminar special
right that's how you do stuff right so
we do that now here's what's interesting
one of the other things you get when you
get membership is you gets live
streaming like we're streaming this all
over the world right now and people paid
something you at home paid to watch this
stream and if you remember you don't pay
you just go into your membership and
you've watched anything streaming so
like and and thank Ballantine's Day
coming up Rachael Cruz and les parrot
will be doing the money and marriage
event in Nashville if you want to come
to Nashville it's not yet sold out but
if you'd only come to Nashville it will
be streamed to financial peace members
free when we do another event it'll be
streamed free we do this event stream
free so several times a year we're gonna
give you other new stuff so as we're
developing new material and talking
about different things like Hogan does a
millionaire which y'all like to I talked
into a whole millionaire thing we would
stream that and put
there's a membership thing that's pretty
stinking cool so it's neat out there
guys so run out there and see guys in
the yellow shirts at the financial peace
booth and those of you at home you can
jump online and find out everything you
need to about it will tell you more
about that in a minute but guys this is
the best time ever because we've taken
all of our experience now and put it
into a way to help you go further and
help you go faster for nine weeks we had
it dialed in for decades we've had six
million people do the nine week thing we
have that dialed in but now we're
darling in the rest of it and we can
help you walk through it with the every
dollar app and and the communities and
the coaches and take you further and
take you faster through this and so we
want to help you it's why we exist we
want you guys to win and so those of you
that are already have gone through
Financial Peace University you need to
understand that is just one little part
of this right and so you get the every
dollar plus you get in there you get
some of streaming and you get some of
the millionaire data stuff when it's
coming up they do stuff when it's coming
out you get in here and you keep going
with us and we're gonna get you back up
get you running again your baby step for
people your baby step five people that
kind of stuff and take you on out so you
need to look at this membership even if
you've been through financial university
because this is not Financial Peace
University it's just part of the picture
now everybody understand that say yes
alright very good cool times I gotta
tell you the results of stuff we've been
able to film with people absolutely
incredible y'all watch this
most stories that have a happy ending
don't feel like it along the way
[Music]
we borrowed for everything blonde a new
couch
go finance it on a new TV go finance it
on a new car
go find and sell my whole philosophy was
credit cards I just worked another week
swipe the car everything kind of started
to crash we started to see our marriage
drop away I personally owed 750 thousand
dollars in debt
I was totally hopeless
you need to decide if you want to be
wealthy or if you want to look wealthy
when somebody told me about FB you I
grabbed hold a bit like a life preserver
it gave me hope that we could make our
marriage work
knowing where your money is going is a
huge life changer nobody owns me anymore
nobody did you opened up communication
big-time all of a sudden we were back
together a crusade we changed our family
tree I am here to do my debt free
screams how much of your bait all four
hundred and fifty six thousand eighty
nine thousand hundred and twenty
thousand three hundred ninety-four
thousand free it opened up a whole new
world of giving the peace and financial
piece actually comes from out the
register prosity being able to give is
the very best part of having wealth if
you will live like no one else later
you can live and give like no one else
[Music]
and it is amazing
you